i i saw that cowboy's
owner future owner he's got a bunch of
titles stephen jones the son of jerry
jones
said that the biggest mistake they've
made as a front office was not signing
quarterback dak prescott sooner and he's
right he's absolutely right i'm just
glad he admits it so many times
there's something that's obvious but ego
pride whatever prevents people from
saying what what everyone else knows and
maybe that's why stephen jones said it
because
everyone else knows now i doubt that
jerry jones would say jerry jones would
say
we did this at the right time this it's
a
lame impersonation i'm not i was kind of
half
trying to and not really trying to
because i knew it would sound more like
ross perot
but regardless jerry would say we did
this at the right time
we did everything just right this was
exactly what we planned to do
no and this is the message
to all other teams out there this is the
flip side of the carson wentz jared goff
cautionary tale
you don't want to give a guy a big
contract after three seasons at the
quarterback position
when maybe you're not 100 sold that he's
the guy
on the other side when you are 100 sold
that he is the guy
you don't want to screw around
especially if he wasn't a first round
pick
that's what made it even worse for the
cowboys on the plus side
they got four years of dak prescott at
bargain basement prices
but with only four years to free agency
which meant franchise tag
last year second franchise tag this year
maximum leverage for dak prescott
because
next year he would have gotten a 44
raise over this year's ridiculously high
franchise tag salary
they had to do that deal and because
they didn't swoop in
the moment the window opens and remember
the window opens
upon completion of the third regular
season not
third postseason or third full year
you don't have to wait until the start
of the league year in march the minute
the gun sounds to end the last game of
the player's third regular season if
it's a drafted player
any round that's when you can go in and
sign them to a new contract and i said
time and again they should have had a
package ready to go
and you've still got playoff games to
cap your third season you've still got
injury risk you've got one more year of
your contract you know what's gonna
happen with your career
if they were sold on him then that's
when they should have swooped in and you
know what
maybe they weren't completely sold on
them maybe they wanted to see what he'd
do in a contract year and then maybe
they wanted to see how it would go
in his franchise tag year even though he
broke his ankle in week five i i don't
know if they were
100 sold but based upon the contract
they've given him
based on the fact that last year they
used the exclusive level of the
franchise tag it tells me they were sold
so the point is this for as far as we're
concerned right now
the browns and baker mayfield the bills
and josh allen
the ravens and lamar jackson if the team
is sold
then buy that guy's contract rights well
beyond
today if you're if you're not quite sure
then you let it play out you're taking
the risk for example baker mayfield has
an mvp year maybe the browns are 100
soul
maybe they want to see what he does this
year will he regress like he did in 2019
or will he go to the next level like we
saw him during the second half of 2020.
if they wait and he goes up price goes
up
that's the risk now for the browns i'd
say
based upon what i've seen wait a year
for the ravens i wouldn't wait
i wouldn't wait i know some people are
not completely sold on lamar jackson as
a total package quarterback i think some
of that may have something to do with
the offense they run
but the ravens have completely
reconfigured their offense for lamar
jackson they're sold on this guy
don't wait josh allen and the bills do
not wait i talked about that a week or
so ago i think they're playing with fire
frankly if they wait
on josh allen's contract because his
value is only going to go up and up and
up now is the time to making
an offer he won't refuse and that's the
lesson to be learned
from what stephen jones has admitted
about the cowboys failure
once they knew that dak was their guy to
get that deal done because look
once you know that's what you want to do
every day you wait it's only going to
get more expensive
it's only going to be more complicated
because the closer the guy gets to the
open market the more leverage he
acquires
the harder it's going to be to convince
him to not at that point
roll the dice and see what happens
that's what dak prescott had as a
practical matter
he had one more year with the cowboys
and after that
a ticket to the open market with no
restrictions from the cowboys
and they needed to offer him something
that would get him to trade that in and
it took a huge contract to do it because
they waited
as long as they did hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports